la journée de campagne nouvelle fois été
marquée par le procès de l'ofii parce
que c'est l'ancien avocat de stephen
harper qui est désormais à la barre
emmanuel cet avocat il s'appelle
benjamenta ruines qu'est-ce qui nous
apprend aujourd'hui mais il est venu
dire sous serment venue confirmer
essentiellement ce qu'il avait dit à la
grc lorsqu'il avait été interrogé fait
qu il ait une demeure convaincu que
lorsque joe wright lui apprit que c'est
lui-même qui faisait le fameux chèque de
90 mille dollars pour défrayer les
dépenses de mes deux filles et bien
benjamines perrine est convaincu que oui
novak était dans la pièce qu'ils
participer à l'appel conférence et
d'écouté je pourrais même vous dire où
il était assis sur perrine qui affirme
aussi que lorsque j'ai appris ce qui le
regarde et son collègue henri nowak
pressé de voir si celui ci réagissait et
qu'il n'y avait eu aucune réaction donc
finalement l'ancien conseiller légal de
monsieur un peu vient contredire
formellement tout ce qu'affirme le
premier ministre lui-même depuis 2013
les membres de sa campagne électorale
depuis quelques jours et nador ait sous
serment qui dit vrai ça va très
certainement faire l'objet des débats
politiques des prochains jours mais
d'ici là ce matin avant que ces
révélations soient faites il faut dire
monsieur harper a tenu à réitérer sa
confiance envers oui novak son chef de
cabinet actuel je vous laisse écouter
emmanuel on est à deux mois des
élections il va encore se passer
beaucoup beaucoup de choses mais a quand
même ce matin un sondage qui fait
beaucoup de bruit on parle d'un tsunami
orange npd en perspective au québec oui
crop a sondé les québécois et il voit
finalement offre un portrait d'une vague
de popularité sans précédent je voudrais
on peut peut-être regarder les chiffres
ça donne les appuis du npd à 47%
imaginez-vous et libéraux loin derrière
à 20% le bloc à 16 % ce qui veut dire
que l'effet du siècle du mois de juin ce
serait complètement dissipé le bloc qui
revient dans son territoire un peu
traditionnelle des dernières années sur
monsieur beaulieu et le parti
conservateur à 13% mettre un certain
bémol des observateurs politiques les
sondages d'été comporte une part de
risque mais c'est certain que monsieur
mulcair lui était plutôt content une
certaine inquiétude dans les rangs
libéraux mais aussi dans les rangs
bloqué spéciaux merci manuel au revoir